he is a professor at Princeton  University in dr. Cornel West alright  yeah doc Oh though where's the rest  oh it's always a blessing to be here how  you all doing alright bye see you now  they've been chomping at the bit to talk  about socialism because that has been  the big buzzword in the campaign this  week but I wanted to wait have you here  start the discussion about socialism  this seems to be the last thing they're  throwing they're absolutely at brother  Barack Obama and I wanted to get your  feelings on that and do you think that  this is sort of a veiled way of getting  at a racist angle socialism in other  words he's gonna take money from good  people and give it to the black well for  me it's just an exciting moment to be  alive when you see that kind of  desperation